I had lost everything I had in life I'd
recovered from cancer and I had nothing
left and then managed to rebuild a
little bit of equity it's like the
Marines you know you have been in the
fight you've been wounded but get back
up again and that's what we did
[Music]
I've lived in hotels for virtually all
my adult life you get a little bit like
a gypsy so my home is where my tempest I
[Music]
grew up along a river a small river in
Norway so I like water but if I should
be absolutely brutally honest I'd like
to see water from fixed land and then
I'd like to see land from a ship docked
like here in Dubrovnik and then we can
go back on our genomic or a cup of
coffee but I think the fascination is
really not the water we are on but it's
a place to be
it's so fantastic to take our guests to
other destinations but not when you'd
meet people in different culture you
really figure out we're pretty much the
same and I think that really will help
defuse a lot of the tensions we have in
the world I have a favorite book called
up the organization by a guy called
Robert Townsend he has one statement
I'll try to see if I can find it so he
reads excellence if you don't do it
excellently don't do it at all
and I think that's a mantra where we
following by
when we started biking ocean cruises
very few people gave us a chance but one
shouldn't care too much about what other
people think I thought it could be done
and we did it
hi guys how are we today
uh-huh so this is my favorite seat in
the house that's it here and we have we
can enjoy some more arch my favorite
artist is really white among where I
have in the owners cabins it's again
simple subdued not too busy
I do not like to make decisions I'd like
to set agendas once you have their
agenda won't see other facts that
decisions make themselves
I don't really care what my legacy is in
a sense when it's over is over but I
hope that a Viking will continue to be
seen as a leading company in providing
meaningful experiences to serious people
[Music]